living in the old city of nebles for
more than two decades yusra Hunter is no
stranger to read by Israeli forces
the grandmother says trying to wash away
her grandchildren's fears has never been
harder
the youngest Naya is not yet two years
old but words like shooting and soldiers
are already part of her vocabulary
every other week or so there is an
Israeli raid Naya could hear the
shooting and cling on to her mother we
often make stories up say it's a game so
she is not as scared but this is not
normal nothing about our lives under
occupation is
several weeks ago three fighters in a
house nearby were targeted in an Israeli
military operation 11 Palestinians were
killed in the worst such trade
unoccupied West Bank in years since
January Israeli forces have killed at
least a hundred Palestinians mostly in
raids in the occupied territory
the Israeli Army says it targets those
it considers the security threat
the effects of such trades go beyond
those killed or wounded by Israeli
soldiers Palestinians say an integral
part of the strategy is to show force
and instill fear with the aim of
deterring them from taking part in
activities opposing the occupation
men here believe Israel seeks to control
more than just their lands to maintain
its decades-long occupation extending
that to almost every aspect of their
lives
you go home not knowing when they'll
knock on your door walk the street
worried they'll raid any minute this is
what terrorism is
I don't decide where to go or when I
don't leave nebulous because of the
checkpoints the occupation doesn't allow
me in Al-Aqsa and for me that's
important
we can't plan at all a 20-minute Drive
can take up to three hours things can
change while you're at the checkpoint
such continuous oppression is part of
Palestinians everyday lives
calls brittle violence is
over the years a buildup of events has
undermined how Palestinians perceive
their present and future as individuals
and a collective these continuous waves
of unseen indirect violence that are
bloodless and go on quietly change the
course of lives and the way we Embrace
and think of them what's possible and
what's not
Muslims around the world are marking the
end of the fasting month of Ramadan in
Nablus isra says there is little room
for Joy this aid but it's been a normal
day with no blood spilled and no horns
demolished so this one is worth
celebrating